[Music]
do you guys see yourselves
doing youtube um cool
until you hit 100 years old huh
doing that i don't know one of the most
straightforward questions
i mean what do you mean by that because
like do i see myself making content
until i'm 100 or specifically youtube
the platform
because i think platforms come and go uh
making content for the rest of like
until you're 100 i hope not
if i'm alive [ __ ] you
do you see yourself dancing until you're
100. at 100
if i if i'm dancing at 100 i'm [ __ ]
i'm a god
that's amazing i'm trying to retire yeah
so i could do the real [ __ ]
what's the real [ __ ] take pictures of
starfish underwater underwater
yeah i would also agree like if not
making content in like the later part of
life because like things have just gone
so well that you don't need to do that
anymore
that would be fun but you don't do it
because you need to you do it because
it's fun
yeah that part i think that's a little
50 50 in the adult life because i
realized that
i mean i've taken long breaks and then
i'm like something's missing
and i started vlogging again and i'm
like oh that was missing
making content i enjoy it don't get me
wrong but creative outlet
i like creating that's the thing so like
even if i like took
uh a picture of a cool starfish right
it does it doesn't have to go on
instagram i could blow it up on a nice
little canvas
and hang it up in my wall technically i
created content and maybe only like 20
eyeballs will ever see it
but i'm very happy with it okay let me
rephrase the question then
uh the job that you were doing when you
were 23 years old can you see yourself
doing that until you hit 100.
oh yeah i don't think i worked when you
were 23 you didn't work
i think i was a student oh okay i could
be a student until i'm 100. i could be a
student i'm 100 for sure hell yeah be
around [ __ ]
cute ass girls all day well when you're
hungry
oh [ __ ] well it's not pedo if they're
like 23 too
assumingly the students grow with you i
i thought it was
your you guys are all the same age and
it's a hundred years
no you're an old man around children
you said like that doesn't exist already
okay the whole reason why i'm asking
this is because there's a story
of a california state worker who is
celebrating not only
oh actually oh yes not only her 77th
year of service but also her 100th
birthday
on the same day whoa yes so she
her name is may lee and she is the
longest
tenured employee with the state of
california
working as a financial analyst for the
department of general services she got
the job on her birthday
yeah pretty much back in the 1950s 1943
she started working before world war ii
ended
what the [ __ ] she's worked through 10
governors
i'm surprised she'd even fossilized what
the [ __ ] she's a hundred years old
what do you think her salary is though
you think there's like 2 million goddamn
with all the seniority i don't know but
what if she started
when the rate was like you're making
like 10 000
a year and then they gave her little
raises oh [ __ ]
that'll be so funny all right so i have
a video that's fifteen thousand dollars
i know i have a video to show you guys
with may lee
she's so cute she's my auntie damn
that's so dope oh yeah
wow here we go oh empty just as easy to
do it by hand and fast and then put it
on the computer do her work i've been
standing for the last
since 1970 the last 50 years i've been
standing up
she is very meticulous in all the
reports that she writes
most people would look at her and say
she should be maybe in a rocking chair
on a porch somewhere
she's still coming and contributing
to the seventh may 12th 1944 invited her
so maylene
tell me about your wall of fame oh
there's just all the rewards
given to me she wants to express don't
focus on the negative
try to always look for the positive i
think i
did the best i could with my life i'm
happy
she's so cute yeah so the reason why she
got invited to the senate
my auntie is because uh she
played a role in helping change the
california constitution for asian
americans
which once banned chinese people from
working
in the government so she helped wow
chinese people were banned to work in
the government
yeah i mean they were informative i mean
the exclusion act i get
but i thought after they lifted that
they allowed that's crazy yeah she said
that she said i sat down
and wrote to at to the at the at the
time lieutenant governor
they invited me to the senate on may 12
1945.
it blows my mind that people
are still alive today from our history
books like like during that time
i feel like she thinks everyone's a
little [ __ ] that's what she's saying
be positive yeah because she's probably
been through so much [ __ ] [ __ ]
like you know people that like i guess
like for our for our
period this pandemic is probably one of
the craziest things we've ever been been
through you know but i think if you've
been through
other [ __ ] like like the the effects of
this pandemic
although it sucks and there is
unemployment and people don't have jobs
and we can't do what we want
um unemployment is kind of
like the main focus right it's not
straight up poverty
where you don't know when your next meal
is gonna happen it's not the great
depression yeah you're evicted from your
house you're [ __ ] homeless
so our our like worst case scenario of
of what we're going through right now is
nothing close to what a lot of these
people went through
that's true they're way tougher so tough
yet yeah and like and so she's
also they also say that she's super
meticulous
in all her reports and they were saying
that reports are usually
like one or two pages typically can you
guess like how
how many pages 100 gotta add one on each
year 77
getting closer 1943
[Laughter]
20 pages no five what
you said two that's already like over
200 increase 64 pages
is on her reports i would hate reading
her reports
why the [ __ ] she writes so much i don't
think she writes fast either from what
it looks like
how many husbands does she gonna live i
don't know i don't know her entire life
story that's a hundred years you might
have outlived her own children yeah does
she have children no
uh they do mention she has a family but
i don't know
much about them that's cool that she's
still working too that's cool that they
have no plans to retire either they're
just gonna let her die at the workplace
is that like workers comp they're like
an insurance thing there hey you wanna
go out to lunch she's just [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] i'm just kidding
she does do that already yeah but then
the next time she does that they're like
may stop messing around
she's like oh dude i know they're like
oh [ __ ]
sounds real damn it she's like just
damn dude what if she's like i'll drive
guys
it was like i don't know why do asian
grandmas have such
super powers that they can live to like
they can outlive
turtles and [ __ ] you know it's so cute
too um so they're saying that she's the
only employee
with two workspaces she has two cubicles
she earned it because she needs the base
yeah and then you guys like quickly saw
that wall of her
all of her like photos and like
certificates and achievements and stuff
and then uh there's also a lot of
mementos
from her travels she has traveled to
more than 150 countries around the world
and and she she like they asked her like
do you think you're gonna still travel
like after this pandemic and she was
like no the walker doesn't do very well
in foreign countries with the nice
cobblestones
she's been to over 150 countries as a
financial analyst
for well maybe on vacation or work yeah
like probably
just for vacation or maybe her 100 years
on this planet gave her a lot of time i
know
right maybe she's like on some cia stuff
yeah i know she's a spy
can you imagine her being a spy dude
they're like forget the history books
that's fake
go to the source they do mention that
like one of her co-workers are like oh
my god she's such a sweetheart
she's the state's treasurer like every
time like we walk in together she'll be
telling me the history of
she's a relic dude she was there when
everything was built
that's crazy that's so cool ridiculous
she's just older than the state
it used to not be called california oh
my god it's like oh this building was a
dirt
rubble yeah imagine seeing like your
environment
drastically changed throughout the
decades because even just in my short
life like i've i've seen
areas be transformed so i'm like i can
only imagine like what she's seen
so cool it's super cute but can you
imagine being one of the co-workers and
they're like oh when am i getting
my report back oh went to may oh my god
it's gonna take like three years
or you want to get promoted and you're
just waiting for them to retire
and she's the uh she's she's like your
top and you're like
[ __ ] there's been someone waiting there
for 60 years yeah because usually people
retire and they're like i'm gonna
[ __ ] finish i'm 60 something she goes
i got 40 more years baby and you're like
[ __ ]
they're like they're like we're
celebrating mace hundreds you're just
like yeah cool
she actually still drives her own car
and she plans to renew her license later
this year to be fair
she's got more driving experience than
all of us that's crazy so they don't
force people to retire in the government
huh
no you can't it's illegal it's
discrimination no one goes
you're [ __ ] old get the hell out of
here you slow ass
just kidding just kidding it's a
government job though right can we look
at how much she makes
uh california government
financial analyst 77 years of tenure
yes 77 wow 77 years
of working that sounds like something
you made you made up
i got 77 years of experience doing this
shut the [ __ ] up dude people don't even
live that long it's like
it's like a thousand dollar raise every
year she's like i'm staying alive [ __ ]
i wonder what she uses her money on
because she just seems like those
workaholics that
love just routine traveling obviously
150
freaking do you think she's staying at
the ritz she seems like
very like you humble a modest motel
she seems like a modest she's not a
baller but what if though she is a
baller she's like getting mad hookers
and like she's like living it up and
that's how she's like
the secret to the secret to youth
is lifting it up and then that's that's
what she did
the last quote in the article is really
cute from her it says
i think i did my best i could in this
world both in work
and life and with the family so i'm
satisfied with my life i'm happy
balance she likes balance you think
she's looking for a quote because then
she's like oh man
my end is coming i need a good line to
go out on she seems like somebody who's
like accepting of her end already
in celebration of her they did say
positive thinking
just gives people mad life and then you
know how her co-worker is like yeah
she's always trying to tell you to stay
positive
and look at the good things in life and
it's like that seems to be the
correlation between people that live a
long age just want to remind everybody
out there to stay positive
and look to the good things in life here
we go i would like to meet
lee maylie the grant gregory
wanna you know live up to the reputation
three years work experience
i want to see a bitter old lady saying
shut up i'm 150 and i'm still alive and
i hate the world
and there's plenty of that too hello
guys
thank you guys so much for watching all
of our videos and i know it's been a
million years in the making but we
finally got just kidding news merch
yep so make sure you go down to the
store below and you can run around
yeah you can get a piece of jk news and
thank you guys for supporting
thank you bye-bye
you